des dizaines de travailleurs de soutien
de l'éducation sont de nouveau sortis
dans les rues pour se faire entendre à
Toronto parmi eux run fergusen un
technicien informatique du conseil
scolaire du district de Toronto dit que
la loi spéciale adoptée plutôt cette
semaine ne l'a pas découragé
de manifestyle lundi pour défendre mes
droits de la seule façon possible dit-il
à tes côtés samedi se trouvait des
collègues du Syndicat canadien de la
fonction publique mais aussi des
enseignants et des membres du public
ces gens là et moi je suis avec eux la
fermeture c'est pas bien mais s'ils ont
pas le choix il faut aider les profs il
faut aider pour l'éducation nationale de
nombreux conseils scolaires ont passé à
l'enseignement en ligne pour le moment
prétextant des enjeux de sécurité en
l'absence des aides enseignants employés
d'entretien et autres travailleurs de
soutien c'est une fut toutefois pas le
cas au Conseil scolaire francophone vit
à monde car je dis une lettre a été
envoyée aux employés pour leur rappeler
qu'ils étaient tous attendus à l'école
et que ceux qui feraient la grève
s'exposeraient potentiellement à des
amendes de 4000 dollars par jour en
vertu de la nouvelle loi un message qui
fait écho ou mot du gouvernement mais
qui a choqué certains parents
au lieu de de défendre au moins le
s'excuser je trouve ça
comme il est auparavant à inacceptable
dégoûtant
moi personnellement il y aurait dû
dire
Radio-Canada de son côté le gouvernement
octarien Martel que s'il adopte la ligne
dure avec le syndicat c'est parce qu'il
faut absolument éviter plus de
perturbations ou courants